on this episode we talk about Instagram
and museums auditing yourself and
finding out you're a two or a three and
I ask myself a question
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 107 of the askgaryvee
show hope everyone's super well feeling
a really strong groove today very
intense business day tight strong epic
meetings feeling like I'm moving the
vaynermedia machine 500 vaynermedia
employees deep in the right direction
vayner/rse the fund having some good
meetings feel really really business man
like today which should pretty much make
for a very good show hope everyone in
the vaynernation is doing super well Big
Ups to all of you appreciate all of you
and India let's get into the show Colton
asks Gary Vee is all about being one
step ahead of the game
what are your social media plans for
2016 Colton my plans for 2016 17 18 19
20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 2 3
4 35 6 37 38 39 40 and beyond I went
further than you guys thought my plans
for all those years are the same thing
which is my friend and everybody of
internation I don't know what my 2016
social media or business or or brand
building plans are because I for the
billionth time on this show Colton and
me counter-puncher I react to the
opportunities in front of me at that
moment January 2016 6 months from today
is an eternity in the game Microsoft is
buying up stuff snapchat is growing by
the second instagrams
add product could be incredible if it
gets deeper and more detailed like it's
Facebook father company Facebook
continues to be much stronger than
people think Twitter's video product
evolves you know influencers especially
long tail call it 1,000 to 100,000
people following them continues to be an
interesting arbitrage where's the
whitespace where do all of you all of
you think that you should be doing this
and
should it be why right this is X and I'm
always in Y so my 2016 plans are to play
more Y right you know play in the white
space find the arbitrage market where
people actually are I didn't know
podcasts would become interesting again
you know I didn't know that you know
snapchat well I did but like maybe three
years ago I didn't know that snapchat
would get older you know you know I
didn't know the periscope and meerkat
would be invented no let me exist
six months ago I mean periscope did it
was bought by Twitter but then brought
internally these things didn't in theory
exists six months ago these are things
we talked about there are people in the
vaynernation that have used them to to
grow their audience like like I don't
think people understand and I'm Frank
you know what real-time right now
because I'm continuing to test we're
going a little bit different directions
to fajn I'm going to bring up periscope
let's we're gonna periscope right now
instead of meerkat
let's just see what just went let's just
see right like you know ask here we go
yeah this is real-time [ __ ] yeah scary
you know actually it's not the broadcast
for a second family nature stood me I
like that
okay okay good so askgaryvee behind see
there's a whole lot of gray
sorry guys hope you enjoyed yourself for
a quick second boom it's just tea
Rockefeller we go you haven't heard me
say that before that's what I always say
on the side d-roc what's that yeah you
like that right yeah there's India got a
lot of hearts yes here we go
all right I go so my friend to wrap up
this long ask question I'm not sure but
I'm gonna react just like right now I
had a feeling that I wanted a periscope
and that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
react to the opportunity
front of me and that's why I don't plan
too far I had you know what I'm but what
my plan is my plan is to play in the
white space the underpriced
arbitrage of the consumers attention and
the places where I think uniquely you
can store retail that brings value to
those people for the moments in time
where they matter econ search banner
YouTube Twitter you know the narrative
of my entire life
Greg asks what the hell are people
thinking when they write essays in their
Instagram captions we're here to look at
pictures not read endless [ __ ] reg don't
say we say I you are here to just see
pictures plenty of people like humans of
New York like all these things people
like the long form written context
around a photo reg you can continue to
just go through the photos and you
should and do you and I appreciate that
and 90% of the people are down for that
as well but I see an emerging
opportunity for people to write
long-form copy on top of photos on
Instagram India Duke do you ever find
yourself reading something that's more
than a sentence let's get on you're not
showing India's I'm not gonna do you
find yourself reading more do you have
you ever read two sentences on Instagram
yeah how about three give me three like
five six
yeah seven and do you like it yeah I
really see reg there's no we there's you
you don't want to read but India and
platforms evolve like that's just the
way it is right and so the answer to
your question is you know people going
to do their thing and you should say I
next time instead of we just the truth
what's going on what's going on on the
scope hey guys askgaryvee show madness
be interesting let's get a little survey
still fun you'll tell me after the next
question how many of you on the scope
right now are watching the askgaryvee
show that means you're watching at least
two out of every three episodes that
would be considered watching give me a
yes know in the comments there alright
and you getting some answers there what
all right Stefan make sure you capture
all the news
kollene asks what happens to museums
when their main point of contact with
their audiences online platforms is
Instagram the Museum of tomorrow Kaleem
it's not that instagrams the Museum of
tomorrow or any photo app that is around
I mean obviously Facebook and Twitter
but obviously Instagram is winning in
the current state in the future there
may be others I don't think they replace
it but because at some level going and
touching and feeling it is still a value
prompt that a museum delivers right I
mean photos of these paintings have been
around forever there was a point in time
where Life magazine if it covered a
museum would be that same replication
because everybody left read Life
magazine an entire country back in the
heydays of print in the 50s and 60s and
70s and so I don't think they replace
them not at all as a matter of fact I
mean as a matter of fact I think they
enhance them I would argue that there
are more people on the bubble of going
to museum they're now going to museums
because they see a great photo on the
gram and it creates a consideration
point so I actually think museums need
to go on the offense some places like
Instagram and use them as gateway drugs
to get visitors to come to the museum
and I highly recommend those museums
show a little personality besides just a
photo of the damn thing because we've
seen the damn thing right show a little
but the personality of the people that
are working there or the little unique
things that make that place special or
like I don't know like the gold faucets
in the bathroom like give me some
goddamn reason
besides the artifact Museum hey Gary
so I audited myself and I'm taking in
serious consideration that I just might
be a two or a three
my question is man is if I am do I need
to go get my college degree like what
what like how do I put myself in those
business in that position because I
really don't know how to you know I only
know how to make doors I don't know how
to walk through them if you know what I
mean and you know I'm all EQ and no IQ
so if I have to go get my degree that's
gonna suck charlie great question I'm
super into this uh I think you know if
you've audited yourself and you feel
like you know you need to have you need
to attach yourself to a leader a CEO
number one a founder and you could be a
supporting cast member because I guess
making doors not walking through them
maybe you get burned I don't know but
you know maybe you understand the
tangible execution not the architecture
maybe you're the greatest Mason in the
world and you need just a really solid
architect to be be successful I would
say it has nothing to do with getting a
diploma it has everything to do with if
you've been auditing yourself and you
started with I've audited myself which I
appreciate and you know for anybody
who's watching this who doesn't
understand auditing themselves and I'm a
number two or three these are themes
that I've been talking about in the
first hundred and five hundred six
episodes of this show which is if you
know yourself you have to self-awareness
you have a real chance to succeed I
would tell you Charlie that you don't
need to get a degree unless you want to
go latch up to a number one that values
that degree and the truth is you've
already lost that game because if that
number one values it they're gonna want
to go with somebody who's got a degree
from clearly in my opinion based on the
vibe of the video comes from a better
school than you would go to take it from
me I mean Mount Ida college isn't like
rolling up any like unbelievable
excitement for anybody who's an educator
and so and so I would tell you your
journey your focus should be finding a
number one who shares your DNA and
philosophy you guys could be similar and
she could just be an architect and an
incredibly strong leader where you could
be that support system so find her find
him find the number one that is the
match to you not find the number one
that you clearly think society is
created to me to me more number ones
actually looked like you on paper so
that I actually think you'll be able to
find that I think number twos when
they're not the straight man or the
straight woman when they're still also a
little bit of magic a little EQ over IQ
make great number twos I said I think
one and two in that play is great I
think three four five six somewhere
along the line you need that straight
you know really straight person and so
your job is to really go out and find
that person find that number one that
matches your skill set that matches your
philosophy that you can really jam with
find your number one like that I've got
a spin
spin for episode 107 and here's how
we're gonna do it I'm gonna ask myself a
question hey Gary
great show totally obsessed my favorite
thing now ahead of Game of Thrones
anyway here's a question for you if you
had a business or a blog or a personal
brand or a book how would you get more
people to to you know know about you and
to buy that - like how would you get
results I guess at the end of the day
Gary I'm asking you how would you get
results thanks love the show Gary great
question looking great by the way you
know one of the things I haven't talked
about in the show a lot I've talked
about it a little bit and I saw people
get value from it in that local small
business business Deb thing is the gross
underestimation of distribution in a JV
joint venture environment there are so
many of you on this show with businesses
that have locked us so heavily into
social media because that's how you view
me as the way to get distribution you
have left some of the greatest
opportunities on the table including if
you are not hitting up the top 100 blogs
in your space if you're selling cupcakes
and you literally aren't spending the
time to figure out what the top 100
cupcake content sites are on the
internet and then sending an email and
saying hey I'm India from India's
cupcake shop I love reading your excite
cupcake day others meet typing the email
I love reading your site cupcake daily
I'm very passionate here's my site
here's my Instagram I would love to
write for you once a week on new
sprinkles concepts or on decorations
that matter like I will give you my
labor for free and what you'll give me
is distribution and awareness if you
don't realize that you know it's a
Kendrick Lamar did anybody pay attention
what Kendrick Lamar did if you don't
care - Lamar is he's a rapper an artist
and he went on to a lot of other albums
as he was starting to get a little Fame
he leveraged that to get on and he came
in trying
kill it on like he basically went on
everybody's track and he tried to be so
much better than the persons whose song
it was that everybody was listening was
like oh [ __ ] that guy's dope like I'm
gonna check him out that's what India
the cupcake lady wants to do on cupcake
daily oh crap that was such a good
thought
let me follow that and so in the
earliest earliest earliest days of me
building my brand I went on wine blogs
and wrote blog posts to contribute and
because I had the chops
you know Kendricks spits incredible
lyrics India writes about incredible
toppings and I talked about incredible
things about wine that people hadn't
thought about that gave me the ammo for
my work to have a positive ROI the truth
is a lot of you don't want to put in the
work because the output of your content
in video form in audio form in written
form isn't good enough you just aren't
good enough what you're selling they're
not buying and the quickest way to find
out is to actually go on a road show put
into 40 hours a day to get yourself into
places where you why can't you email all
500 people on YouTube that have some
level of audience and ask them to be
interviewed on our show or to be part of
it I mean why can't you why can't you
ask why can't you ask why can't you ask
that my friend Gary is what you need to
do if you've got something to sell you
need to go in knock on doors right you
know you got to know how to build them
and walk through them you got to knock
on doors and you've got to ask like can
I guess contribute to your world can I
write a blog post can I can I just show
up and like how do I bring value to what
you need because all these people that
have homes that have audiences they need
more content to feed them content costs
money so people coming in and
contributing it's the ultimate kind of
leverage deal you come and you write for
me for free because I need it because I
need to keep feeding the kids I have in
the room and you need kids for what
you're gonna do and that is something
that ninety-nine point nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
of you are absolutely not doing enough
of putting in the work to get in front
of audiences to be discovered putting
out a picture on Instagram and holding
your breath and hoping somebody's gonna
see it
because you use the hashtag isn't enough
go out and take it and that my friend
Gary is what you should do if you want
something to happen two minutes what do
thing about that I got my calories
question got me riled up question of the
day what is your parents name you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering yes
just parents they Rick and Susan really
are we breaking periscope I don't even
know charlie
here we go I really don't plan again cuz
I love it so much I really I think I
need to make just do it again I think I
need to I think we need to make make
sure everybody on periscope season so I
want to make this video go viral I love
this question this is a great question
by the way I think I actually get it out
me too brother
yeah that sucks I hate squeeze hill
Charlie right try to eat a tour of the
facility Gary what's up hey Gary you
said sent on new platforms that people
go to one and see that hey what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up what's up sup sup sup sup sup
sup sup sup sup sup sup sup sup yo yo
what
is that right only first hundred people
can pop comment it's pretty crazy
everybody it's good to see you spaz I
don't think I'm spazzing Mexico big ups
college or Z in the house I like that
it's the fog do me a favor
go give them a tour 16 15 and 12 and
bring it back all right all right good
let me just say something quick hey guys
so I'm gonna go back to work
Stefon here is going to give you a tour
of 16 15 and 12 at vaynermedia I hope
you enjoy it hope you enjoyed the show
hope your life is phenomenal hope I get
to see you one day see ya